borders are reasonable how about that
[Applause]
the law is the border that stops someone
from stealing your laptop and if it's an
Apple laptop well it's the sort of
laptop that a social justice warrior
would carry and then the social justice
warrior is going to be very irritated if
you happen to purloin their laptop and
then you might point out to them you
know it's a border that protects you
from having that thing taken and they
say well the border should be open it's
okay man no problem you hand over that
laptop right now
and everything else you own too if you
don't like borders and you can get rid
of the damn walls in your house and you
don't need doors on your bedroom either
and we can keep an eye on you whenever
we want and so much for borders one of
the things that really differs between
liberals and conservatives between the
left and the right is the right is in
the right leg tight borders between
things it's part of being conscientious
at every level conceptually sexually
familial II provincially nationally the
right says look let's keep let's keep
the borders between things pretty de
state and the left says yeah maybe not
because some of those borders are in the
wrong place and a little bit more free
flow of information wouldn't be a bad
thing and the thing is they're right but
so are the conservatives and that's why
you have to talk it's like well we've
got some borders that's a good thing
maybe some of them need to be moved
around a little bit and that's what the
political dialogue is for but that
doesn't mean that borders themselves are
a bad idea they're a great idea because
without borders everything mashes into
the same untenable state of
undifferentiated chaos and you can't
live in that and so the people who are
trying to tear down the borders
conceptually politically and practically
what they want is the chaos that that
would bring they either want that or
they're too foolish to know that their
pursuits will produce that so let's
let's let's be a little bit clear that
if you stand up and say yeah borders
they're okay they've got their problems
but they're okay that doesn't make you a
bigot beyond redemption it just makes
you someone with some sense and it's
actually okay to be someone
some sense limits on immigration are
also reasonable well we need to figure
out what those limits are and that's
what the bloody political dialogue is
for but the fact that it should be
limited to some degree is also
reasonable otherwise why not just open
the borders and let everybody come in
well the reason you don't do that is
because a complex system cannot tolerate
extensive transformation over too short
a period of time now you want immigrants
to come in especially if they're the
sorts of immigrants who are likely to
contribute properly to the success of
your polity and lots of immigrants do
that I mean I think the vast majority
for example of entrepreneurs in the
United States come from the Indian
subcontinent so great it hope bring them
over they're highly educated they're
extraordinarily productive they make
lots of new businesses and then they
pump money like back like mad back in
India good deal but that doesn't mean
that we hacked we have our arms are open
to everyone immigration policy because
it's complete rubbish all that means is
you're not thinking about it so and
here's a coded to that for conservatives
here's something I've been thinking
about this a lot lately
it should not be assumed that citizens
of societies that have not evolved
functional individual rights predicated
policies will hold values in keeping
with such qualities so we could say look
there are a lot of countries in the
world that are not governed well the
vast majority of them right and they be
not governed well forever and to me that
means that there's something wrong with
the values that are held collectively by
the people who've established those
policies well you shouldn't be naive and
assume that merely because you moved
them to a new country they're going to
let their innate democratic longings
flourish it doesn't work that way
[Applause]